whether it's a television an aquarium a
flower pot or a radiator Bob check esna
turns everyday objects into cardboard
art installations and puffeth will the
enticing thing about working with
cardboard is that it's very easy to work
with and handle you can fashion objects
in various oversized formats monument
and coulis cardboard is easy to come by
this is like to become it's not as a
graphic designer from Berlin three years
ago he developed a special interest in
brown cardboard boxes
at some point there was a trend in
graphic design to return to the real
world to construct things rather than
photoshopped them why I even turned to
cardboard I don't know I probably didn't
have any paper at home and this
cardboard has become the material of
choice for the decor and the artists
apartment yeah as a cardboard chainsaw
a cardboard machine gun and a cardboard
face
but he makes these creations elsewhere
at this artist's workshop here he draws
cuts and folds his popular cardboard
artworks his detailed designs have a big
appeal and not just to art lovers Maya
Nestor couldn't've my first client was
an automaker we constructed an oversized
boom box around a mini and had it driven
through Zurich with loud music playing
this was to promote the city's
international radio festival that was
followed by orders for a blazing
fireplace and one for a slot machine for
a communications firm esna has received
inquiries from around the globe here
he's designing a surveillance camera I
chose a security camera because it's a
classic image in street art and because
it's an object that's relatively quick
to create its
Edna's own creation so he has no
blueprints or instructions to follow
after two hours work the camera housing
is finished three hours later the
details are done - now he just has to
decide how to present his art whenever
possible Montag is not likes to exhibit
his work in public spaces
passers-by seem to approve is it a
proper camera that was the real camera
yes really good
the boss super but cameras oh that's
cool that's reachable [ __ ] well done
they thought it was real but that's
funny cuz there's already so much paper
hanging around here so Bartek edna's
cardboard creations will continue to
grace the streets of the German capital
at least until it starts to rain